LAURENCE MORONEY (VOICEOVER):
Welcome to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it would be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler,
and have coffee with them.
And just chat about what
they do, how they do it,
and why they do it.
And today we're going
to do exactly that.
Welcome to "Coffee
with a Googler."
I'm Laurence Moroney and today
I'm here with Jennifer Lin.
And Jennifer's from
our App Indexing team,
and she's going to
tell us all about it.
So, Jennifer, welcome.
JENNIFER LIN: Thanks
for having me here.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Thanks for being here.
So, App Indexing, what is it?
What do you do with it?
JENNIFER LIN: So App Indexing
is where we get Android and iOS
apps into the Google index.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
JENNIFER LIN: So we can
crawl, index, and surf content
for Maps, much like what
we've done with websites.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
JENNIFER LIN:
Developers are gonna
love App Indexing,
because it gets them
organic installs and
traffic to their app
from Google search results,
search auto-completions,
and now on Tap.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
So if I understand this
right, it's like now,
if I open my phone, instead
of me searching on the web
and finding a
website and viewing
that website in the browser,
I can actually search.
And if that content is
within an app that I have,
then I can go
straight into the app
and get maybe a richer
experience than I
would in a mobile browser.
Is that what it's all about?
JENNIFER LIN:
Yeah, that's right.
So with App Indexing,
Google search
can help users find information
from apps that they've already
installed-- apps that they may
not have known have answers
that they're looking for.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
JENNIFER LIN: I've got
some exciting stats
that I want to share with you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Tell me.
JENNIFER LIN: We've indexed
50 billion deep links
from thousands of apps, and
25% of our Google searches
return deep link results
to signed in Android users.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
JENNIFER LIN: We also have
several success stories
from apps published
on our developer site.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
JENNIFER LIN: For example,
"Daily Mail", a newspaper app--
LAURENCE MORONEY: The
British newspaper, yeah.
JENNIFER LIN: Yup.
They have seen 22% boost
in search impressions
for their app users.
And those app users spent
20% more time per visit
in the app, reading
and sharing articles.
So that's great!
So I want to show
you an example.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
Yeah, cool.
JENNIFER LIN: So let's say I
am checking out the Grand Hyatt
Hotel in San Francisco.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
JENNIFER LIN: And
so I search for it,
and I get a bunch
of results from apps
that I have installed,
like TripAdvisor--
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
JENNIFER LIN: --Yelp,
booking.com, Expedia.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
JENNIFER LIN: If I click
on any of these titles,
it'll take me directly to
the Grand Hyatt San Francisco
page in the app.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So it's really nice
that I can find this
content by searching,
but what if I
don't have the app?
JENNIFER LIN: So if you
don't have the app installed,
then Google search
will also help
users discover
your apps once you
integrate with App Indexing.
So another example is let's say
I search for patio umbrellas.
I see results from
wayfair.com; I also
get results from overstock.com.
Now I'll also see
an option to install
the Wayfair app or
the Overstock app
to go and view their
information on patio umbrellas.
And when I install, I'm
taken to the Play Store page.
And I accept the
app permissions,
and the install happens.
And I can hit the Continue
button to go directly
to the patio umbrellas
page in the Overstock app
without having to go
back to the home screen.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
So it's not like
breaking the workflow.
I'm able to install and then
go straight to that content
right away.
JENNIFER LIN: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's pretty neat.
So, I can see where this now
makes it very interesting
for you to market your app.
That the apps with
the best content
are the ones that people
are going to see, right?
JENNIFER LIN: Mm hmm.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
so if I can build an app
with great content,
then people will
be able to find my app
as well as my content.
JENNIFER LIN: That's right.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And that's what
you were talking about earlier
as potentially a new marketing
channel.
JENNIFER LIN: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So, I think
developers are gonna love this,
you're right.
But how do they get started?
JENNIFER LIN: So
there are two steps
to get started
with App Indexing.
The first step is
they have to add
HTTP deep links to their app.
And then the second
step is they just
publish those HTTP deep links,
so Google can discover them
and we can start crawling
their deep links.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I see.
JENNIFER LIN: And
so the simplest way
to publish their HTTP deep
links is to associate their app
and their website.
And all they have to do is just
go to the Google Play Developer
Console, log in, type in
their website address.
And then they can log into
the Google search console
and accept that website
verification request.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
JENNIFER LIN: And that's it.
Just make sure you test that
your deep links are working,
they open correctly.
And then you get to measure the
performance of your deep links
on Google search with our
Google Search Console.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's
as simple as that.
JENNIFER LIN: Yup.
That's it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
JENNIFER LIN: And you
can go to our website,
which is g.co/appindexing,
to find all this information.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So g.co/appindexing.
JENNIFER LIN: Yup.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's a
pretty easy one to remember.
Is there an app for
that that's app indexed?
JENNIFER LIN: No.
[LAUGHTER]
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So thanks, Jennifer.
That was really awesome.
And thanks everybody, and
hope you enjoyed this episode
of "Coffee with a Googler."
We've got lots more great
information on App Indexing.
There's a great dev byte
that you can watch here.
And we've linked other
stuff into the description
of this video.
If you have any questions for me
or any questions for Jennifer,
please leave them in
the comments below.
And subscribe to the
Google Developers
channel for more great content.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]